one mark come on your set what did you
do what did you do
nah I said enough gods
all right guys wardrobe is clear make
them miss later
quiet freeze lock it up help Claire can
you do that help again
barely so yeah bored of a like you you
turn and then it's not like a jump turn
and get up to go over okay and action
James and I wrote both the scripts so
actually since I last time
no actually Corrections you did not
write any months we did five days per
script well five on the first one seven
on the second so what we did you're
gonna you're gonna jump in anyways and I
want to I don't have to smack you on
camera so what happened was I had seen a
film that I was not impressed with and
it inspired me to do mom anything it was
the idea like don't let perfect be the
enemy of good
so called up James I'm like I'm pulling
the trigger on this I've got a bunch of
investors who put money into other films
before my thoughtful eyes let's jam it
out and get it done
so James had a distributor in front of
his approaching a distributor in advance
is something that really helps
especially for this film what I did is I
had my movie pernicious which is coming
out in theaters soon that all the
distributors saw when I was playing
festivals and they made bids on it and
the distributors that we didn't end up
selling the film to I approached and
said hey you know
they put in an offer for it and I said
hey if I made a film in the same genre
would you buy it and they said yes and
so they pre bought the film and so these
films were pre-sold before they were
made it was very easy to finance them
based off of they were already sold
before they were made so it's like hey
one once the film is delivered you get X
amount of dollars from the distributor
it's very easy to say hey can you
finance this because I'm literally
basically borrowing money from you for
like a little bit of time and then it
comes in he said specifically what he's
looking for as opposed to making up a
movie that you like this is my passion
project
it was here's the distributor rewards
they basically said as long as I'm
writing and directing which on one eye
and then I swung it as a tube film deal
that I would write both with his AK
exact with the wrecked one and I would
direct one and then they said that it
had to be like ghost house types so like
you know John were films with a
supernatural element that's that's
what's big right now for for genre so it
was haunted house film with the ghost
girl and inside that niche we could do
whatever we wanted so we came up with
about 12 different concepts to him he
chose which ones he liked and then we
wrote them and we literally wrote them
over Christmas and my girlfriend is very
very kind in understanding so over
Christmas we were locked in our offices
sleeping there writing 17 hours a day
jamming it out and we got we wrote
restoration in five days for the first
draft and then Bethany we wrote in seven
days and then we both went our separate
ways to do our polishes on each so I
would directed restoration he was going
to direct Bethany so I polished
restoration in Bethany
so once we had that we already had the
distribution I talked to my investors
and at this budget we had a good mg
minimum guarantee so it wasn't that much
of a risk financially it was a real
thing to move forward with so we did and
it's you know it's micro budget films
it's hard it's really hard but we have
fantastic crews
that we're working with and then we have
begged for every favor we can get so we
then crewed up cast up locked it down
and started shooting and we did them
back-to-back so we did we're doing six
day weeks my restoration was 14 shooting
days six day weeks and three days down
and then started method verse or game
shooting days I miss short of a schedule
because we have 14 days to shoot the
movie and it's a 95 page script you're
shooting 6 to 10 pages a day which is
pretty intense when I was in Thailand I
had a 28 day shooting schedule so I was
shooting like 3 to 4 pages a day but if
you look like you know if you write out
a bunch of stuff like in here I have
certain things of like this is how the
character feels like she pulls back in
saying something childlike anger and
hate behind her voice but it isn't loud
it's more subdued stuff like that it
gives you more of a moment that you're
able to just go in on how you already
intended for the scene to go you work
with the actors during the blocking and
some of some of the actors I'm blessed
like to have people like Zack and Tom
Green and Shannen Doherty and and
Stephanie s Dez and everybody who's been
involved they've all put in time before
the movie so I was able to talk with
them about their characters and really
go through all of this so their scripts
match note wise with my scripts so they
already kind of know what I was going
for originally what was layered in each
character and like each character's
backstory past the page so we developed
that together and then it's kind of
comes into clockwork because with all
the stuff like focus or sound from a
plane you don't have as much time to
really work with the actors so you have
to go in and and you know work with them
prior and really get them to where you
want them before and so I played it both
ways which way you wanted here um I
think this time this side but also at
the same time since since your
character's supposed to beat me it
doesn't matter nothing
what alright I just wanted to make yeah
for you for you specifically just
your characters I can be looking up here
yeah quiet and hatchet yeah yeah yeah we
had a rain bar right and so how is that
it was actually a little problematic it
took us a while to get set up and it was
hiding like the stands for it to get it
going but it's it's cool and and the
funny thing is is it that's one of those
things where like I fight for random
aesthetic things we're like you know
there was no reason that it had to be
there other than like I thought it would
look cool if rain was in the background
for one shot so we spent money I'm
having this rain bar because I thought
it was important for how I wanted to
introduce Tom's character because I
wanted him to be coming out of the rain
one of the things that I've really
played with the most on this film that
I'm really excited about is is my scene
to scene transitions like every single
time in the movie there's there's almost
every scene we go into a scene to see
the transition so it's like you know
I'll have a character pick up a coffee
mug and then they'll go to sip it and
we'll cut into a close-up of them
sipping it and when they pull it away
from their mouths we pull back and we're
in a different scene so it's just them
sipping the same coffee mugs but they're
on a different day and a different scene
so finding different moments to have
something that similar art-wise so
you're on that focused on it and then
you're somewhere else I like to hide how
we got from one place to another and I
think it definitely helps with the
fluidity of the movie and also with the
fluidity of the character because a lot
of this movie plays as some cerebral
thing within the characters psyche
almost as if it's the the lead actresses
psyche so it's almost as if like the
entire movie is a quilt woven together
so I don't want stuff to people to ever
know when something ended and when
something begins and we go in and out of
flashbacks a lot so one of the cool
things about that is instead of having
the flashbacks be separate scenes
I'll have the character turn and look
and wee-wee dolly over there and we have
a dramatic lighting shift and it plays
as if it's a little play in front of her
and then they leave the room and so
there's these really cool transitions
that that play out and like the world
changes lights come on art moves and I
got a lot of that from watching the
movie Lone Star if you've seen that so
we've been kind of copying that a little
bit but you know doing my own version of
it but watching it I was like I have to
do that kind of thing that was awesome
so these are certain like I wanted
practical lights throughout the house so
I took pictures of that I'd paintings
that had hold on pictures that have the
mood we'll have like shots from other
movies so these have like definitely the
same kind of lighting that I wanted for
the aesthetic look of the film and so
you go through and you look at how this
is lit and you see like know that stuff
and then now I'll pull up a shot from my
actual movie and you'll see how we
matched it so
and this is what we ended up with this
is still from from monitor on
color-corrected so it's all about having
having that dialogue and that
conversation and you know for me it's
really important to have everybody on
the same page so they all understand the
vision so I always you know that's just
my cinematography file I also have you
know an art file effects file a hair
file a makeup file a wardrobe file and
all that stuff and everybody all the
department heads put their stuff into it
and I put my stuff into it and we
combine and work it out and it looks
like Marcus is pulling me now one of my
favorite things about doing a scene like
this especially in like this location
that we have over here is I originally
had like 14 shots shot listed for this
scene a bunch of stuff prepped and then
when we were doing the walkthrough I saw
this this part of the hospital on this
location and it looked really awesome
and I knew it was gonna look good on
camera
and the lights but since it's such a
tight space I chose this location which
totally made my shot list go completely
out the door because now I can't do any
of the things I originally planned
because it's such a tight space and so
many people so now we're kind of like
winging it a little so it's a it's kind
of fun because it keeps you on your toes
and it's it's very different because you
know I'm very prepared all the time this
is one of the first times where I kind
of just have to make make things up as I
go which is we'll see how it goes we're
going to
that their wine when they're walking
away where he's like move your ass and
he pushes him into the room for that way
it'll go from them to these guys okay
during that whole exchange then we're
going to get a shot of them here well is
walk here three I'm going to get an
insert shot that has to match for a
transition of Kevin's arm going onto
this door and then after that I'm just
gonna let it defense you've had special
okay you make the movie a bunch of
different times you come up with a
concept and write it that's your first
time making a movie then you shoot the
movie then you edit the movie when you
score the movie so you're merely making
the movie four times you know and
throughout the process you the thing
that you thought was gonna be awesome it
was okay that other thing that you
didn't think was gonna be amazing
it was fantastic so you have these happy
accidents especially when you're doing
something with such a brief turnaround
and no prep time that you're finding
happy accidents actually at this point
we've got an amazing crew who's done not
only doing Bethany but it also did
restoration so the I think it's it
smoothes itself out everybody's got long
figured out if they like each other they
don't like each other
and I walked away few people they don't
like hung out with the people they do
like they're all professionals it's not
like someone has a major tantrum sits
down and pouts about it yes we won't I
promise you
the rest because I promise you that
everything is going to clear once
arrested he was he was there the entire
time
and we're gonna talk about your sister
good good all right that's good